der fliegerhorst brunowsky im
österreichischen langen leben wird
weiter ausgebaut die heimat der s 70
black hawk helikopter wird meinen
vorplatz erweitert um den sicheren
einsatz mehrere maschinen gleichzeitig
möglich zu machen sieben millionen euro
werden dafür investiert für
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
ist dieser spatenstich ein bestandteil
einer großen investitionsoffensive in
das österreichische bundesheer und das
über alle parteigrenzen hinweg ist an
der stelle auch ganz offen was muss das
ziel sein das ziel muss sein dass das
kein thema mehr ist das heißt dass auch
über die nächste legislaturperiode
hinweg der budgetrahmen für das
bundesheer außer frage gestellt wird
egal ob iran oder bin welche parteien am
ruder ist sicherheit darf kein
parteipolitisches marshall haben und an
dem arbeiten wir gerade in tests in form
eines gesetzes dann zu tun so dass das
parlament hier angeordneter dann auch
die möglichkeit hat dieses zu
entsprechen und ich bin überzeugt davon
dass jeder auch weiß dass nichts
geschafft wird unabdingbar notwendig ist
für die sicherheit der österreicherinnen
und österreicher für die sicherheit
unserer republik gleich nach dem
spatenstich nutzt hat die gelegenheit
lehrlinge am fliegerhorst zu besuchen
und vier von ihnen zum erfolgreichen
abschluss ihrer ausbildung persönlich zu
gratulieren